moon knight might not be the most
well-known marvel character but he's got
a rich history in the comics all the
same with a new mcu series about to drop
what do you need to know about the
character and the show before you watch
the official trailer for moon knight
premiered during the rams cardinals wild
card game in january 2022 and in
addition to providing fans with a sneak
peek of what the highly anticipated
series might entail it also revealed the
show's release date moon knight is
scheduled to premiere on wednesday march
30th 2022 and like the rest of marvel's
phase 4 tv series we'll stream
exclusively on disney plus as of right
now it's unclear what time the series
will become available for streaming but
we can speculate that it will be similar
to the release times prior marvel series
like hawkeye loki and wandavision which
all premiered their episodes at 3am
eastern time each week we also know that
moon knight will consist of six episodes
according to kevin feige the marvel
studios boss also says that these
episodes will run between 40 and 50
minutes which is in line with other
marvel disney plus series
leading the cast of moon knight is none
other than oscar isaac who is set to
play the titular hero as well as his
multitude of overlapping personalities
moon knight's true identity is that of
mark spector a mercenary who suffers
from dissociative identity disorder and
constantly swaps between several
distinctive identities as the series
goes on the interesting thing is that
these identities essentially function as
totally different characters and it'll
be interesting to see how isaac brings
them each to life on screen ethan hawke
is also set to appear in the series as a
cult leader named arthur harrow who
appears in the trailer and encourages
mark to
embrace the chaos
the series also features french actor
gaspard yuliao who appears posthumously
as anton mogart the alter ego of the
character known as midnight man yuliel
tragically passed away in a ski accident
after filming and moon knight was one of
the last projects he ever worked on
others confirmed to be in the series
include f marie abraham who voices the
egyptian god kanshu lucy thakuray who
plays a co-worker who is close to one of
mark's many personalities and may calla
maui in an undisclosed role
the official trailer for moon knight
revealed quite a lot about the story and
characters that we'll be seeing
throughout the series at the start of
the trailer mark believes himself to be
a man named steven who works at a museum
and admits that he can't tell the
difference between life and dreams he is
tormented by strange visions and
nightmares and doesn't even recognize
the name mark when somebody calls him on
the phone what's wrong with you mark
why did you call me mark
mark's story is as much about fighting
literal bad guys as it is about fighting
his inner thoughts and from what we see
in this trailer it seems like the latter
is a losing battle after a brief montage
of mark's disturbing visions we finally
get to see him don moon knight's iconic
white costume the suit literally
materializes from thin air around mark
as he looks up at the moon indicating
that similar to the comics he receives
his powers from the egyptian god of the
moon khanshu finally the trailer ends
with mark brutally beating some
monstrous looking creature before
turning to the camera it's an incredible
trailer from start to finish giving fans
just enough to be excited about without
giving too much away in regards to the
plot for now it looks like moon knight
is going to have two villains dr arthur
harrow and midnight man it seems as if
the latter will be more of a secondary
baddie as ethan hawk's hero looks to be
the main villain of the series
however it's suspected that there's more
than meets the eye here given that dr
harrow has only appeared in one comic
book issue there's not that much story
in the comic for the show to pull from
either many fans believe the persona of
dr harrow is a red herring and hawk is
actually playing the moon knight villain
sun king a former ravencroft institute
patient sun king has a base of loyal
followers much like we see hawks pharaoh
have in the trailer
both sun king and moon knight have
connections to egyptian gods with the
former obsessed with aman ra and the
latter who is blessed with powers by
kanchu it's also very possible that
hawke's character is an amalgamation of
dr harrow sun king and other famous moon
knight villains only time will tell what
we do know for certain is the
inspiration for hawk's character in an
interview with seth meyers hawk pointed
to one famous cult leader as the
inspiration for his portrayal of dr
harrow
i've based my character on david correct
have you really
yes
moon knight will feature three directors
one of whom directed four episodes while
the remaining pair directed the other
two according to the hollywood reporter
muhammad diab is helming four episodes
solo marking the first time he's
directed an english language project
diab is known in his home country of
egypt for projects like cairo 678 and
clash
but moon knight marks his first
hollywood project per variety the famous
directing duo of justin benson and aaron
morehead tackled the other two episodes
the indie horror visionaries don't have
the longest resumes in the business but
their work speaks for itself they
directed 2019's synchronic with anthony
mackie an episode of jordan peele's
twilight zone reboot and 2017's the
endless in which they also starred the
higher-ups at marvel studios clearly
have been impressed with the work
they've seen from benson and morehead as
the pair have also been brought on to
direct a majority of the episodes from
the upcoming loki season 2 according to
deadline
so far every mcu series on disney plus
has been scripted by a different writer
moon knight will introduce head writer
jeremy slater to the marvel cinematic
universe but this is far from slater's
first dip in the superhero pool he
penned the script to the 2015 fantastic
four movie he's also one of the creators
of netflix's the umbrella academy if
moon knight turns out to be anything
like slater's initial pitch we're in for
a treat he told empire raiders of the
lost ark was actually a big reference
when i first pitched how can we tell
this dark complex story but also inject
some big fun supernatural amblin style
magic at the same time a lot of trust
has been put into slater recently which
gives us a lot of hope for moon knight
he's also painting the script for mortal
kombat 2.
leading into the premiere there's no
clear answer on where moon knight fits
in the official timeline of the marvel
cinematic universe as of now hawkeye is
the latest show on the timeline taking
place in december 2024 it's entirely
possible that moon night is the first
mcu project to occur in 2025 if it takes
place right after hawkeye it's also
possible moon night happens sometime
during 2023 as do two other disney plus
live action series one division begins
three weeks after the conclusion of
avengers end game while the falcon in
the winter soldier is about six months
out loki kicks off in 2012 but about 99
percent of the series occurs in a space
outside of time so it really doesn't
have a solid place on the timeline
eternals shanxi and the legend of the
ten rings and spider-man no way home all
take place before hawkeye with no way
home definitely landing in 2023 long
story short moon knight can fit anywhere
every mcu disney plus series has its own
identity but moon knight is going to
really shake things up in a big way
kevin feige admitted to empire that
things are taking a major left turn with
moon knight suggesting it's the darkest
series in the mcu to date he told the
outlet it's been fun to work with disney
plus and see the boundaries shifting on
what we're able to do there are moments
when moon knight is wailing on another
character and it is loud and brutal and
the knee-jerk reaction is we're gonna
pull back on this right we're not
pulling back there's a tonal shift this
is a different thing
so far every mcu series has held a tv 14
rating including the animated project
what if the way feige describes moon
knight and its brutality sounds like the
series might have earned a more adult
rating than its predecessors but disney
plus has labeled it with the tv 14
rating on its website one thing is clear
moon knight is certainly going to push
the barriers of how far a tv 14 show can
go
for now it looks like there won't be a
second season of moon night but that's
based on a small comment made by oscar
isaac when speaking with jared leto for
variety's actors on actors series isaac
mentioned that moon knight was a limited
series limited means just that so for
now fans likely shouldn't get their
hopes up for a second season wandavision
was also confirmed to be just a limited
series but that's not the case for all
mcu live-action shows so far loki is the
only disney plus series for marvel to
have confirmed to season 2. this
announcement came in the credits of the
first season's finale episode so if we
are getting a follow-up for moon knight
its finale could be the episode that
holds all the answers however just
because there might not be a season two
of the series that doesn't mean we won't
be seeing moon knight again in the mcu
up to this point the title characters of
every mcu series had already appeared in
multiple movies so there was always the
assumption we'd see them again on the
big screen moon knight is the first
title character to get their origin
story in the disney plus series and his
future afterward is slightly unknown
since we know we probably won't be
getting a season 2 we'd have to hope
oscar isaac's mark spector would show up
in future mcu flicks and it looks like
those hopes are due to be fulfilled
kevin feige confirmed to the hollywood
reporter that moon knight would appear
in an mcu film after the series this is
also the case for jennifer walters from
she-hulk and kamala khan from ms marvel
for now your guess is as good as ours as
far as to where moon knight might appear
next but hopefully we'll get some clues
during the show's six episode run he
isn't one of the characters rumored to
appear in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness and there have
been no rumblings of him showing up in
thor love and thunder or black panther
wakanda forever there's no shortage of
upcoming mcu movies though so here's
hoping we'll get more moon knight sooner
than later
cameos in the mcu are common these days
and the disney plus marvel series are no
exception james rhodes popped up in an
emmy nominated scene in the falcon in
the winter soldier wilson fisk made his
mcu debut in hawkeye the x-men's version
of pietro maximoff sword of cameoed in
one division and chris hemsworth had a
very sneaky voice cameo in loki as a
trapped frog thor
needless to say we are expecting someone
we know to show up in moon night rumors
abound that jon bernthal could be
reprising his role as frank castle aka
the punisher in moon knight redditors
have been hoping for this cameo for a
while now especially given that frank
castle and moon knight have a history in
the comics with vincent d'onofrio
showing up on disney plus in an old
netflix role it's certainly possible
there's also speculation that mark
ruffalo might be appearing as bruce
banner in moon knight after he was
spotted in budapest hungary during the
same time the series was filming there
if that's true it seems like there'd be
no better mcu hero to teach moon knight
how to control his emotional issues
that's my secret captain
i'm always angry
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite mcu series are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you